alors que lundi le président de la
république va une nouvelle fois prendre
la parole beaucoup de français
s'interrogent maintenant sur les mesures
qui pourraient être prises autour du
déconfinement si certains parlent d'une
période transitoire ou seulement une
partie de la population la moins
fragiles seraient autorisés à sortir il
faudrait avant ça que de nombreux tests
puissent être effectués fin mars le
ministre de la santé olivier véran
expliqué si on aperçoit qu une grande
partie de la population soit 50 à 70%
est immunisée alors on pourra sortir du
confinement sans risque car la
population fera barrière naturelle
contre toute nouvelle grande épidémie
selon ses déclarations pour connaître le
pourcentage de la population atteint par
le virus tous les français devront donc
être testés sauf que voilà aujourd'hui
la france manque grandement de test le
26 mars dernier il indiqué avoir
effectué une commande
j'ai commandé plus de deux millions de
ces tests qui arrivent sur notre
territoire national et qui nous
permettent de préparer le pays pour la
phase essentielle qui est la phase de ce
qu'on appelle le déconfinement et
sachant que la population française
contre 67 millions d'habitants cette
commande paraît bien mince mais alors
testé toute la population était la seule
solution pour procéder aux déconfinement
alors est ce que c'est la seule solution
faut-il attendre les tests pour des
confiné est ce qu'on a et gilles verdez
vanille oui oui et oui on attend même si
c'est long mais la commande est trop
tard on sait pas fautive en arriver on
ne sort pas avant de les avoir il sera
des tests sanguins pour voir si les gens
sont immunisés s'ils sont fabriqués des
anticorps sinon qu'est ce qui va se
passer syrie
alors à tous salle de sortir un jour on
va sortir eh bien on va rentrer confiné
parce qu'ils auraient une deuxième vague
donc on attend on ne bouge pas avant les
tests ma que cheryl c'est un non sens
ces tests pour pour se dé confiné pour
une raison simple j'écoutais ça n'a pas
de manger coûte et le ministre à trois
jours qu'ils en parlaient et qui lisait
le problème de cette maladie c'est que
vous pouvez le lundi matin à 8h du matin
testés négatifs et le même jour à midi
être positif
donc on vous teste et quatre heures
après quatre années passées au logis
test à l'écologie
je suis d'accord on sait ça on sait ça
60% sophie pour le moment on n'est pas
eu classe dure encore
donc ça sent pas là pas de sens en tous
les cas ce n'est pas assez sûr pour
qu'on puisse te baser là dessus pour
sortir alors ça michael mathieu mathieu
avec les tests effectivement les
premiers tests avec les échos villon etc
oui tu as raison est ce problème
effectivement on teste pas les anticorps
avec la sérologie on a un test sur les
anticorps donc on sait si on l'a
et si nous sommes immunisés alors qu'il
ya que les tests de sérologie qui
pourront nous permettre de sortir du
confinement alors paresseuse on vous
pose la question faut-il attendre les
tests pour tous les français avant de
déconfite et maxime gaming non
franchement si on devait attendre que
toute la population soient testés avant
d'être totalement déconfit ne l'est
vraiment pas sorti de l'auberge
à terme ça peut devenir une solution
faire un medley situation actuelle à
l'heure où les français et le reste du
monde avait qu'une seule hâte que ça se
termine
j'ai bien peur que la sixième édition
d'été viennent retarder la seule
solution c'est techniquement impossible
on va où art et ses 67 milliards sur ce
qui fait déjà trop tard seulement les
stages bien matière à la maison mc cj la
région a créé toi tais toi tu ne peux
pas dire ça à maxime je ne voudrais pas
donner la mort à l'us gilles gilles je
ne vous ai pas donné par l'irak dans
pardon mais on a le temps j la raison ça
va être long ça va être éprouvant mais
c'est absolument indispensable
tous les pays qui est des cons fine
passe par les tests voilà encore une
fois le plus important c'est en fait de
tester les gens qui ont été affreux
automatique
donc moi aucun symptôme sur eux ils sont
pas malades ils n'ont pas de chair et
tous pas rien et pour autant ils ont eu
la maladie et donc leur sérologie par
montrer qu'ils ont développé des
anticorps était sociaux qui mise en page
va donc on doit calculer au plus vite
pour voir quelle est la partie la
population qui a été en contact et non
et qui s'est défendu contre le coc vide
donc alors à pas de géants fête à la
salle hier saïd ya saïd qui feinte oui
très très drôle qui dit j'ai
l'impression que le déconfinement c'est
comme le mariage de gilles verdez on en
parle mais ne m'arrive jamais trahi
voilà c'est bien de rigoler aussi un
petit peu
raide et rené malleville qui s'annonce
est partagé par ce n'est pas une
critique mais je serais plutôt d'accord
avec ce que disent aussi que c'est vrai
que c'est désagréable et puis en plus
voilà et puis les confinements petit à
petit parce que tu parlais de patois
mais active il parlait du ministre qu'il
parlait de séjour le ministre ils
essaient de nous amener relis tes côtés
pour nous faire passer les 40 c du
gouvernement qui a eu jusqu'à maintenant
voilà alors moi j'écoute pas trop ça
mais moi je vais je pas mon cas et les
jeunes qui comme hormones à la prison
alors que je pense que les élections
tous les papas et laisse t il pas mieux
que d de la can qui dort il ya quelqu'un
qui me dit vu le nombre de tests
disponibles le nombre de français il
faudra au moins deux ans pour tester
toute la france voire s'est offert une
envolée à gilles verdez et syrie mais
même si même s'il faut attendre cyril on
n'aura peut-être pas le choix il faudra
attendre mais ce ne serait pas
responsable de sortir sans les tests
donc attendons mois s'il faut rester
conseiller deux ans avant de tester je
reste chez moi ça mais si c'est le seul
moyen
oui mais comment on fait pour les
connaît on fait les gens pour vivre
c'est un problème pour pour certaines il
va voir et me reconnais français qui
vont se retrouver dans une situation
inexplicable
oui mathieu mais c'est la limite de gym
ça il commence bien et puis après aucun
sens dans deux autres attouchements l
économie sera zéro non est ce qu'on se
rend compte du temps que ça peut prendre
un peu plus de 50 % de la population
soit immunisé et créent des anticorps et
pour plus virus tombe ça peut prendre un
temps gigantesque donc la solution
pardon aujourd'hui c'est la prévention
la prévention la prévention c'est
d'arriver à ceux des confiné avec des
gants avec des masques sans les
restaurants sans les boîtes de nuit sans
les frontières et puis s'éloigner les
uns les autres
c'est la seule solution s'il vous plaît
dans deux ans il ya quelques rides à
quelqu'un qui nous dit il ya quelque
chose qui nous plaît s'offir ton et
couvre donne la parole s'il vous plaît
il ya quelqu'un qui nous dit gefflaut
qui nous dit sophie détrompez vous les
tests sérologiques donne un résultat qui
nous concerne pas les dix derniers jours
voilà donc 6 606 voilà indiqué en train
de s'endormir benjamin très fort
non je ne dors jamais série
effectivement moi j'ai l'impression
qu'on ne sait pas grand chose on s'est
eu une seule chose il ya trois pays qui
font effectivement un dépistage
systématique c'est l'accord et
l'allemagne et j'ai pu caler quelle est
le troisième en tous les cas si on veut
savoir où on en est il faut dépister des
gens effectivement ça va prendre du
temps mais c'est la seule façon d'y
arriver sinon on reste la seconde vague
et apparemment et même mieux même accro
du premier discours le 16 mars a dit on
redoute la seconde vague et donc c'est
ça qui l'a fait peur c'est qu'on soit
débordé sur la suite on n'a pas d'autre
choix
voilà alors oui rené mais surtout père
défaite absolue qui sommes capables de
relancer l'économie en phase qui est par
terre
alors oui mais comme à moi pour avoir
durant l'été l'économiste ralph fiennes
convient pas on ne nie pas mais là on
consomme c'est tout mais les gens qui
comme chez mille euros la hisser
l'économie eux et perdu michael tessier
tête mais c'est ces gens là qu on doit
des copies d'un projet d'accord un
géraldine et pour apporter un tout petit
peu d'optimisme malgré tout il faut pas
oublier qu'à la mission discovery
aujourd'hui kit est plein de traitements
alors non pas c'est pas un vaccin et
pour éventuellement aussi imaginer aussi
un dea confinement dans les prochains
mois effectivement on peut aussi avoir
de l'espoir et tous les professeurs y
avait un professeur de lariboisière qui
disait que peut-être d'ici un mois un
mois et demi en ré des premiers
résultats
comme par exemple la chloroquine hésite
romanesque la donne alors attention on
l'a vu le test sur le test je vous le
dis sur discovery
il teste pas complètement ce qu'avait
demandé le professeur à ou puisqu'il
n'était fait qu'une partie 1 bien sûr de
son
de ce qu'il a toujours dit le dr house
puisqu'ils testent que la chloroquine
mais la chloroquine pour le dr house
elle associe un deuxième médicament qui
me parlent et est exactement donc c'est
un problème quand aura lieu le
déconfinement écouter ce qu'a dit
edouard philippe
mardi à l'assemblée nationale le premier
ministre et il a voulu prévenir tout le
monde que c'était pas pour tout de suite
regarde je suis le député voilà que vous
évoquez la question de demain ou en
vérité d'ailleurs même plus tôt d'après
demain c'est à dire ce qui se passera
lorsque nous serons prêts à procéder à
ce déconfinement dans certains parlent
donc à seulement je parle peu je réponds
aux questions qu'on pose mais je parle
peu pourquoi parce que nous sommes en
train d'y travailler
ce n'est pas pour demain aujourd'hui
l'impératif c'est de faire en sorte que
le confinement fonctionne donc
aujourd'hui c'est l'heure du confinement
et lors du confinement va durer et c'est
tout à fait difficile à supporter pour
beaucoup de français j'en ai
parfaitement conscience mais c'est
indispensable si nous ne voulons pas
nous retrouver dans une situation qui
serait pire encore que celle que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui
voilà géraldine qui voulait ajouter
quelque chose
non non je trouve qu'il ya quand même
une sorte de rétropédalage quand même
d'edouard philippe qui a été le premier
à prononcer le mot de déconfinement
peut-être un peu de manière prématurée
et leurs 900 kg et voilà tout est dit ou
là là là attention j'en ai parlé
beaucoup trop tôt et on en est vraiment
pas là alors moi je moi je vous dis la
vérité
moi je pense que les autorités elle doit
se dire et j'espère que ce que c'est ce
que va dire le président mine de rien on
va pas se mentir
ils ont jamais été confronté à ce genre
de situation un moment il n'y a pas de
honte à dire franchement y'a pas de
honte à dire
yann puisque c'est une situation qui est
unique et qui est vraiment on n'a jamais
connu dans l'histoire voilà du monde
moderne
donc forcément ce qu'il faut dire moi je
pense que c'est un moment il faut dire
voilà je vous dis on essaie de faire le
mieux qu'on peut pour vous mais
malheureusement je vous dis c'est une
situation qu'on n'a jamais anticipé
c'est une situation à laquelle on a je
n'aurais jamais cru être être confrontés
donc voilà je vous le dis on essaie de
faire le mieux mais c'est vrai que il va
y avoir des moments on va changer d'avis
il va y avoir des moments où on va dire
on va partir comme ça et puis finalement
on va dire non c'est peut-être pas la
bonne solution
il y aura des moments vous faut pour
vous parler de déconfinement et puis
peut-être un autre moment va dire non
forcément on peut pas des confiné tout
donc il faut qu'il vous explique aussi
qui tâtonne et je pense que ça lui
france est vraiment peuvent l'entendre
ils peuvent entendre qu' on va être
confiné voilà pendant peut-être encore
un mois deux mois trois mois
et bah qu'est ce que voulez vous lisent
un moment moi je vois et c'est ce que
j'ai dit hier je vois que les français
aujourd'hui
eh ben ils se plaignent pas il essaie de
faire le maximum
il souffre mais ils souffrent en silence
et ils sont exceptionnels moi je le
trouve dans cette crise voilà je le dis
et je le redirai que ce soit les
personnes qui travaillent qui sont
exceptionnelles ou les personnes qui
sont chez eux mais aujourd'hui un moment
il n'y a aucun gouvernement qui avait
prévu de se retrouver face à une crise
mondiale comme ça ni donald trump aux
états unis ni en corée ils ont bien géré
le truc mais bon voilà ils ont vu
arriver ni en allemagne ni où on est en
angleterre où vous avez vu que c'est une
catastrophe ni en italie ni en espagne
donc forcément un moment je pense moi
qu'il faut dire la vérité
et quand on sait pas eh bien il faut le
dire faut dire voilà même si c'est pas
trés voilà je veux dire qu'on sait pas
mais on essaie de faire le mieux et on
essaie d'avoir les meilleurs
spécialistes autour de nous pour essayer
de vous donner les meilleures réponses
et les meilleures solutions gil 6
d'ailleurs ce qui a renforcé la
crédibilité du premier ministre c'est à
partir du moment où dans sa
communication dans son expression il a
dit à des questions je ne sais pas tout
parce que le gouvernement au débu disait
je sais et se trompaient contre lui a
repris les choses en main il a su dire
je ne sais pas il ya des choses qu'on ne
sait pas donc jamais dans votre sens
j'acquiesce quand on ne sait pas on ne
sait pas et c'est ce qui a déjà repoussé
sa crédibilité tout à fait mais je ne
peux pas savoir oui oui et après on aura
mathieu un enseignement sénat rené
d'abord wade il voit justement est
sacrée il ya personne qui sait et je
trouve que tu sais que macrom il devait
parler ce soir va voir là bas je sais il
a jamais parlé de cette fois et il est
allé voir là où d'abord parce que même
lui son entourage du politique la
politique des connaisseurs il veut prime
time avant fin de la vie ddd vrais
scientifiques pour savoir que tu as peur
dans l'avenir et les politiques qui
devraient tous faire pas à les voir
libres et ses petits que les vrais ceux
qui savent et non et pour les conseils
de valdivia là et si aujourd'hui la
paperie de la porte la marque rose c'est
pas qu'ils étaient allés voir le
professeur à août à marseille et
j'aurais jamais ticket mars
au tacle ce soir et peut-être pour ils
ont froid et la dernière la pause mais
mathieu oui c'est vrai qu'un homme
politique et médecins sont des gens qui
doivent être doivent être humble ils
sont passés quelque chose qu'ils n'ont
jamais vu je donnais un essaim j'espère
qu'on pourra en parler lundi avec dit
mohammed il ya un mois il ya une étude
qui est sorti et qui montraient que les
fumeurs pouvait aggraver totalement le
risque d'avoir le coc vide est ce que
moi je suis exactement pas dû parler
voilà oui est sorti une étude depuis
hier sur bfm est partout et bien sûr
internet qui dirait que la nicotine
justement éloignerait locaux vides et qu
on pourrait peut-être trouvé à vaccins à
base de nicotine et je peux même vous
dire que c'est aberrant
hier certaines pharmacies qui
aujourd'hui sont en rupture de patch les
genres ce coq des patchs c'est pour vous
dire qu'on passe d'un extrême à l'autre
en un mois c'est sa marque sur les mains
donc laissez faire les pros
effectivement on ne sait pas en les
médecins ne savent pas ou ne savent pas
et c'est insupportable dehors qu'en ce
moment il ya 70% de français qui sont
médecins on sait pas et bien tout le
monde est médecin oui sophy doute sur la
nicotine il faut peut-être attendre les
tests mathieu toi qui n'as pas envie de
bosser parce que justement il n'y a pas
encore eu de test et j'ai pas envie que
les gens qui portent en décryptant de
suivre se disent tiens on va se coller
des pages animaux s'y passe a dit qu'on
entend non je le connais tu fais une
connerie on en vendait demain demain on
va d'un projet meda gibus pour pas avoir
pour régler les moyens locaux vides
attendait de moi je vais vous dire moi
j'aimerais qu'ils me disent il faut
manger de larissa au moins je serai
content s'il fallait manger de larissa
je peux vous dire que le covin il peut
arriver un les mecs un mois j'étais
petit j'étais trempé dans un plot
d'harissa la laissant donc convenir que
je suis bien tranquille oui il de
l'ombre castaldi je vous comprends tout
lui dans ces séries vous avez raison
c'est la vérité je sais que je pense que
personne ne sait rien le concept même
pas la forme que prend le virus a
maintenant il est près de pau il ya une
semaine c'est lé tout apprécié la fière
et honnêtement ils ne savent pas du tout
d'où ils en sont et la vérité s'il faut
mettre les deux passions leur faire
confiance
il ya des médecins des gens qui
cherchent des politiques qui pour le
coup tâtonne et les vérités moi j'ai un
pote qui est un mec qui est un peu
informé il m'a dit on gère à 48 heures à
deux jours ils ne savent pas où ils vont
et ça c'est la version ils sont perdus
laissons les faire et c'est vrai que
vous avez annoncé li fu long il faut il
faut le dire
les français sont extrêmement
extrêmement serré en séries et et voilà
etc sont magnifiques les frontières si
au pays à fanny qui nous dit
le gouvernement nous a menti sur
l'utilité des masques difficile alors de
ce final c'est vrai ce qu'il nous
raconte
et c'est vrai que ça a été il ya eu un
problème à l'allumage voilà le jury
c'est vrai que depuis mais moi je pense
que je vous le dis la transparence c'est
ce qu'il ya de mieux dans une situation
pareille quand on sait pas eh ben on dit
c'est pas un mec on sait et personne ne
vous en voudra de ne pas savoir parce
que c'est une situation inédite
si on sait pas comment réduire le
chômage ou comment là bien sûr on peut
leur tomber dessus au débat pourquoi tu
as été élu alors ainsi tu sais pas voilà
mais là sur une situation comme ça dans
le monde entier personne ne sait et vous
voyez que tout le monde tâtonne alors y
en a qui ont des meilleures solutions
après il y en a mais il ya des pays où
on dit pour l'instant ça se passe très
bien
donc c'est pas comment ça va se passer
dans deux trois quatre semaines aux
états unis moi j'ai entendu il ya trois
semaines tout le monde disait vous avez
des états unis comme il gère bien la
crise aujourd'hui les états unis voient
là en plus de morts que tous les autres
pays
voilà il bat des records tous les jours
des records malheureux mal en bien
entendu mais c'est vrai que voilà donc
on peut même pas se rendre compte on
sait pas en angleterre il avait dit on
va laisser on va laisser voilà le truc
comme ça et on verra bien ce qui se
passe eh ben ils ont vu et forcément
l'angleterre c'est une catastrophe aussi
et on espère voir la même mine de rien
que boris johnson
leur premier ministre va vite se
remettre de cette crise du coronavirus
merci en tout cas d'avoir réagi regarder
ce qu'on pense les téléspectateurs s'il
vous plaît de cette histoire est ce qu
il faut d confiné faut-il attendre des
tests pour tous les français avons des
consignes et oui à 73% non à 20 degrés
pour sow